This video describes
a device that
can capture the human figure
through walls using RF signals.
We place our device
behind a wall,
and it can see the
silhouette of a person who
walks in an adjacent room.
The device works
correctly even if the room
is completely closed.
For example, if a person
stands behind the wall,
the device's output
looks like this.
In particular, the
output on the right
shows the background
in navy blue
and the various human body parts
in red, orange, and yellow.
Here, we can see the person's
head, chest, arms, and feet.
How does this work?
The device operates by
transmitting wireless signals
that traverse the wall,
reflect off the human body,
and come back.
At every point in time, only
a subset of human body parts
reflect the signal
back to the device.
Here, we show the output of
a device as the person walks.
At different points in
time, different parts
of the human body
reflect the signal,
and the device captures
multiple snapshots
at various points in time.
It then combines the snapshots
through a reconstruction
algorithm that allows the device
to recover the human silhouette
through the wall.
Here, we can see the person's
head, chest, arms, and feet.
The device can distinguish
between different people
behind the wall.
So for example over here, we
asked two different people
to stand behind the wall.
And this is the
output of our device.
By training on
different subjects,
we can use a classifier to
distinguish between them.
The device can also distinguish
between certain human postures.
If the person stands straight,
the output looks like this.
Well, when someone
stands in other postures,
the device's output
reflects his postures.
The device can also track human
limbs from behind the wall.
Here, we show a scenario where a
person draws a shape in the air
and we show the output of
our device to the right.
The device can trace
the person's hand
with high accuracy.
We compared the
device's output to that
of a Kinect placed directly
in front of the person,
and show that
connects up with red.
In comparison to Kinect,
our immediate error
is around 2 centimeters.
For more information on
how the device works,
check out our Project web page.